بعد فوضى تجنيد المدانين مدارس روسيا تغرق
بفوضى تربويه عارمه تحت عنوان عسكره
الاجيال المقبله فالمناهج التعليميه تفيض
بدروس وانشطه لا منهجيه تدعم افكار دعم
الحرب والموضوعات العسكريه والوطنيه كما
تقول نيويورك تايمز هذه الجهود جزء من
حمله كرملين الموسعه لتعزيز المحتوى الطبي
العسكري الوطني بجميع المدارس العامه
البالغ عددها اربعين الف مدرسه الجهود
تشمل جميع المستويات من رياض الاطفال الى
الجامعه تهدف لتدريب الاجيال القادمه على
تبديل الجيش وتعزيز روايه بوتين القائله
باندلاع حرب حقيقيه على الوطن الام وفق
تعبيره وتحقيقا لهذه الغايه اعلنت وزاره
التربيه والتعليم والدفاع ان التدريب
العسكري سيكون الزاميا العام المقبل لطلاب
الصف العاشر حيث سيقع على عاتق الفتيات
تعلم الاسعافات الاوليه في ساحه المعركه
فيما يتدرب الاولاد على تشكيل الحفر
والتعامل مع الكلاشنكوف وغيرها علما بان
جهود التلقين بدات بشكل اساسي مع ضم روسيا
لشبه جزيره القرم الاوكرانيه عام 2014 لكن
الحرب الاوكرانيه صرعت الخطط التعليميه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات